I want to really thank you from the
bottom of my heart for coming here today
there are some really amazing talks and
probably if I wasn't here I would
probably be somewhere else watching one
of those amazing talks so you chose me
and I appreciate that
so I'm get started right away let's see
if I can see this though
since the fifth grade Brian Russell
Davis has been solving his problems with
computer code
it's a Karuna software company axiom 88
solves problems for the military and
business but the code that inhabits his
heart and wine lately is named JL hello
i am g lae i can help you find a safe
place get someone to talk to or alert
the police so this is an a I except
basically what it does is it detects
responses and input from the user and it
is smart enough to give back an
intelligent response JL is built to help
women escape their abusers it's
cloud-based there's no app to download
it's access to a phone number and
available on anything that sends digital
messages they can be on facebook
Messenger it can be on skype it can be
on Alexa anything that has kind of like
the messaging component to it okay could
you please provide your name and
location so that we can send help your
way Brian gave her a voice for us but JL
can be discrete silently guiding her
charges safety means for someone who has
a moment you know maybe maybe the
abusers in the other room maybe the user
you know went out went out for an errand
or you know whatever but they just have
a little bit of time programmers have
the software ready to launch but Brian
needs local domestic violence experts to
help him teach jail I mean I would
naively asked you is it hard is it hard
to create an app that's smart enough to
help you know
I think it's hard because you have to
engage so many people to be a part of
the process and that's what I'm hoping
to do is to get the collaboration of the
community that part is part the coding
part is not hard that's what we do so a
text in the night from a desperate woman
or man could soon be answered by
artificial intelligence built to have
the answers to provide the help and to
quickly save lives it's us so it's going
to do what we needed to do and it's the
collective if our collective thoughts
and experiences being put to good use so
who is jail jail is my daughter's mother
but it is also the name of a character
in Bible she's a woman very strong woman
that confronted the enemy and and
confronted them by herself and she was
very brave
so right
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm gonna start this off a little
different and because I get this great
sense of coming to this place coming to
Missouri that there's a lot of history
here and even when I was traveling
across the cobblestone roads and some of
the roads are exposed to can see the
cobblestone and what was conjure in my
mind is like all these images from the
past and and and there's certain
traditions where we we think it's very
important and sacred to to acknowledge
the ancestors those who came before us
and and for us to ask permission because
their blood has spilled on this ground
that they asked permission to give us
the chance to speak and that our words
will be acceptable to them so I do ask
that and even if you don't count sacred
then then you know the history of this
place is very complicated and there's
lots that have gone on here and Michael
Brown isn't the only one that has fallen
and there been other brown boys sitting
on their knees with their eyes shut
hands behind their heads fingers will
open pinkies up saying he and even do
nothing what you want they throw her on
the ground this he called them all punks
retro blue and like Jordans tons out
over the black teens cuff just the right
amount to make them bunch around the
caster's the way he likes just ran out
boxer briefs wearing tighty whities with
the white t-shirt and the breeze catch
it just so pressing tight against his
chest but for the red hole is getting
wider and the blood is soaking into the
fabric and pooling on the grounds who
looks down automatic and the dark
pavement gets darker when it's wet and
he's losing his balance slow if his
hands on his head so his face hits first
and his eyes go dead and the air sucked
out of the world with his last breath
times have made a choice of what to keep
and what to throw away everything in
grain comes to a point so sharp you get
cut a piece of day and it bleeds on the
ground keep your knees on the ground
they'd be long
keep your knees on the ground where
they'd be
that was a piece that what that David
Davi digs recited and performed at the
brown baccalaureate this year and when I
watched that on YouTube I was like man I
gotta go to brown I just love the the
intertwining of the humanities and all
the things that it means to us and I
have signed up for Brown actually um I'm
going to be doing a master's degree in
cyber security and so that kind of
brings me to the beginning of who li
inserts impressive credentials here so I
am a software engineer I'm also a
graduate of Morehouse College I've been
a software engineer for about 20 years I
was very very blessed and honored to
have worked at Pandora
for four five years before the Republic
and was one of the principal engineers
working on what we call digital
engagement so basically I was the jerk
that was making it possible for all they
had to pop up but what what I what we
like to do at Pandora was to make the
ads very engaging to make it a part of
the process of listening to music so
this idea of like machine learning and
data science and and and that being
integrated into our user experience like
I had no idea but the word data science
met while I was working at Pandora but
that's exactly what we were doing and so
I'm I'm it's very very important to me
that that I'm not only and I I'm taking
my experiences in my education and
putting it to good use like the speaker
said yesterday but that if also
impacting lives so that kind of goes to
my next point of Who am I I am a
survivor of domestic violence so I know
it's very rare you might look at me like
ice that big guy you know I'm saying at
the dreadlocks everything you know I'm
saying how could how could he be afraid
of anyone and and fear is the thing that
has no color and no size no no any of
that I mean and also it has no gender
even though more women are affected by
domestic violence than anyone on the
planet so
being a survivor of it I understand what
goes on and I understand this idea that
there's a cascading failure that can
happen in your life where you know you
find yourself in a place and you don't
really know how you got there and you
don't really know how you how your
choices contributed to the fact that
you're in the spot right now and but you
also blame yourself for all the things
that happen to you you know there were
several times that I would be kneeling
in in my bathroom as saying the most
powerful prayer that I that I knew just
trying to pass the time over or when the
yelling would stop and I would kneel
there and I would say out of the night
that covers me black as the pit from
pole to pole I thank whatever God's may
be for my unconquerable soul in the fell
clutch of circumstance I have not winced
nor cried aloud under the bludgeonings
of chance my head is bloody yet unbowed
beyond this place of Wrath and tears
looms but the horror of the shade and
yet the Menace of the year's finds and
shall find me unafraid it matters not
how Strait the gate how charged with
punishment the scroll I am the master of
my fate I am the captain of my soul
now I'll just keep on singing over and
over again and so a yelling would stop
and and then and then I would venture
out and and then think about all the
things that happened up into this point
and even even years later after after I
escaped that that very very bad
situation then that same person would
force their way into my house and and
and threaten me to my face in front of
my children and and I called the police
but they didn't come and then I tried to
get them out on one tape but it was
erased
you see see my exes was a assistant DA
so it definitely knows no boundaries any
of it all the violence and we have to
find a way to stop it so this is my top
welcome sorry for the really dramatic
intro
so I want to do one correction here and
I want to say that uh because I went to
another talk and so we're gonna call
this machine intelligence for victims of
domestic violence right so what is JLA i
say we went over this really quickly
with with the video it's a real-time
decision making in jeannette uses our
natural language process and inputs and
to route survivors to resources based on
their situation so i'm just really
simply you know someone if in a
situation and they need to get out and
they can text to the service and try to
find that and so what i did was use a
really simple natural language
processing it kind of like intent engine
API that AI and then i got a whole bunch
of hot line scripts so these are
domestic violence hotline scripts that
have been curated and kind of like you
know in use by people who understand
domestic violence from a psychological
perspective people who are advocates
people who who are survivors of domestic
violence and you think this kind of like
this this all of this information to
create these intents so you know maybe
you are messaging to jail and jail
you're saying hey I need some help
or maybe you're saying you know hey I
need someone to talk to and so basically
what it's doing is just trying to
respond to every single one of those
needs and it's gonna get smarter and
better I'm going to show you some other
ways that it gets a lot smarter in a
second so question is why are we doing
this well domestic violence is very bad
and domestic violence is spreading it's
alarming the amount that is spreading
the the next this is I'm not going to
kind of inundate you with law statistics
because I think it's out there you can
find it if you want to know about it and
this talk is not necessarily about all
the sistex that are going on but about
how were using technology to stop it
but this this statistic right here the
the 65 percent of women killed because
of DV are murdered at the moment they
try and leave that was
50% when I started I'm doing this
research so Scott and then another study
came out and it's higher so what does
that mean it's like at that moment that
they say that they're gonna leave and it
could be an hour it can be it could be
30 minutes that can be you know week or
whatever they you have a 65% chance of
getting murdered in that moment
65% so when I saw that and also the
second it's also the last point right
here where it says it's the third
leading cause of homelessness so if you
don't if you do survive and get out okay
then then you probably be homeless like
on the street so you know what I talked
about that cascading failure and we
understand that in terms of Technology
you know if you look at a network you
can understand what cascading failure
means and if you look at biology you can
understanding you can understand what
cascading failure means if you look at
structural engineering you can
understand what cascading failure means
this is idea that one failure leads to
another and that it weakens the
structure so much that the whole thing
could fall apart and this is what's
happening in people's lives when they're
living in situations where the person
that they love and the person that
they've put their trust in is basically
trying to kill them and yeah so this is
this is the reason why we're doing it
I'm gonna skip this work for a second
I'm gonna go to this video real quick
and I'm gonna play this I want you to I
want you to watch it carefully and I
want you to tell me when she's in danger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
when was she in danger anyone have an
idea right right the woman she met him
she was in danger it's not not when you
know she got mad or he got mad or
anything like that a moment that she met
him she was in danger yeah so this is
why we have to understand at a deeper
level what this means because because
this is happening this affects people
individually but it also affects
families okay as a survivor one of the
things that my ex did to hurt me way
after the fact is when I got what I was
able to get away from her then she
decided to brainwash my child my child
was at the time 14 she's now going to be
sophomore in college
pretty soon and I haven't talked to her
since then and I have two boys as well
that weren't affected by it so but she
was able to get to my daughter and she
was able to brainwash her and if
thinking that I was doing something to
her when she was the one that was like
breaking down doors and taking it off
the hinges and yelling and screaming and
threatening you know waking up in the
middle of night talking over me writing
journals you know saying that she would
you know she would kill me all this
stuff so it has a cascading one thing in
the cascading effect that it has on your
life is is is tremendous so the reason
why I want to bring up that cascading
effect right is because if I was to tell
you or any of you guys you know software
engineers or network engineers and that
you know that you had to fortify a
system right that had the the
vulnerability to cascade and failure
what would you do or did you do any
ideas
isolate isolate what
right right right so so so the so if you
know that this is a point that's gonna
fail think if they okay I know this is
gonna feel for gonna back up for this
you know I'm saying is kind of like an
idea of a low balance or what else this
is a kind of hard abstract question
being preemptive right right so so you
know that this so so when something
fails and then you know that you know
you have a back up but but being
preemptive and trying to kind of stay
away from the feather is just another
thing okay I won't press you guys to
bicycles and can tell you know so our
question but this is this is the
frustration that's happening right now
in the DV community this idea that and
my my my interfacing with them is that
so we have these ways of dealing with DV
but they're you know they're very
antiquated okay
this problem is not this problem is very
old and but the solutions are very new
so you know if even or anything about
you know women's history and I've been
studying it more and more because I'm I
also the CTO of the UN's Global
Leadership Initiative temporarily cut I
need to find a woman to take my place
very very very dearly but when you
understand women's history they
understand that this is something that
didn't to start yesterday and has a very
very long history and I was you know in
my research I was very very curious is
like when did this start like was there
a time that women actually had equal
rights and and were seen as as equals
with them with man and and I think the
further back you go on history the worse
and worse she gets you know you go back
to the 70s and you know they had to ask
her you know their their husbands to get
permission to get a credit card and go
back to you know kind of like the
eighteen hundreds and and and somewhere
around there were when men would
actually come to court and you're like
well she's my wife I have the right to
beat her you know that kind of thing and
that didn't end you know and it wasn't
really insulin 90s that people were
really like getting arrested for it
that's just crazy so it was it became
illegal like I think in 1851 someone
around there and then it was until the
1990s
that we began to see people actually get
in trouble for it is just completely
crazy so that's what I went further and
further further further back to realize
that that it was an ancient Greece when
there were some cities where women had
were seen as equals in some cities were
they were not and it was all about the
ideas that were being propagated at the
time and the ideas and I really really
hate this because I'm a philosophy major
I really loved Aristotle but Aristotle's
one of the people that said hey women
are not women are women are not equals
women should be kept in the house and
women shouldn't have any rights we
should they should be kept away from
everyone and a lot of it's really
complex and has to do with like sexual
freedom that kind of thing and lineages
and that kind of thing but if I went
further back into ancient Egypt and in
ancient Egypt they did actually have
equality and there were high priestesses
and landowners and people that had you
know you know equality and I'm not a
geologist or anything like that so you
could probably check me on that but uh
yeah so so the reason that were we're
tackling a very very old problem okay
we're unwinding something that's a very
very very ancient and so when we're
doing that this whole idea of being
pre-emptive and responding to failure in
systems okay it's very very important
and this is why not only in the divi
community but in all kind of like
nonprofits we need to start using
technology because the technology was
designed to do is to do both of those
things to be a back-up plan okay when
something fails and to be pre-emptive
when something is okay and so yeah Jael
is not going to replace a real live
person talking on the phone trying to
guide someone through a process but it's
another thing another Avenue another way
to stop that domino effect to be
pre-emptive or to respond when something
has completely failed so here's some of
the other things that we're doing
predictive situational awareness and
scenario curation so I told you that
work for Pandora and I think that you
know working there and this whole idea
of curation is like really kind of like
embedded inside of me now if this idea
that we're gonna start you know
ingesting all this information from 911
calls and all of the all of the hotline
calls and all that all the times that
women talk to these these services and
try to start deconstructing like like
the way that things happen in the way
things fall out so we begin to know and
understand what to look for and how to
respond to those things and win and in
the situations where people survived
what was the difference what was the
action that was taken now the reason why
no one wants to touch this with the
10-foot Pole is because it has legal
liability written all over it
okay no one wants to be responsible for
the fact that if a I says something or
fails or has a crash and then you know
someone dies then what then they're
gonna sue JLA I okay I'm not afraid of
that because for me that is basically
being being being frozen by an inaction
because of fear of failure and we don't
live any of our life like that in any in
any other facet if we would just be
stuck in our house and not move okay so
we have to find a way around that we're
gonna find a way through it and to be I
think this is the good idea is that once
we curate all of those all of calls and
all of those hotline scripts
okay we're gonna be better than even in
some instances I mean I mean the same
mistakes could happen with a person okay
if a hotline person comes in and isn't
not in a good mood or you know they can
spill coffee of themselves like anything
can happen right so that that could
cause that same failure so the idea here
is that we're gonna take all that
knowledge and put it at the fingertips
of jail and this is what you know
machine learning and AI and natural
language possum is good for
so what are our challenges what everyone
what are our needs we need money right
now I've worked on this so much that
I've come neglected all the other parts
of my business I've basically you know I
don't have any clients right now as far
as you know my my dev shop that I run
and we were working on this 24/7 it's
really really important that we get some
funding so that we can take care of the
other two things up there we need a
lawyer or two no we're not no we're not
no I put on Kickstarter because I feel
like what we need to do is we need to
form a you know if I once III in the
fossil currently just there's just a
logistical work that needs to be done
the other thing is that I know what it's
like to build something completely by
yourself and I'm not gonna do that again
all the successful startups that I see
and business is my kind of thing ever at
least two people you know people that
are kind of holding each other
accountable and like working together
so that's other things new partnerships
and we need engineers and we need money
I say that again so the you know this
this idea of using AI this idea of using
and this and the AI is not that you know
sound like it can't you know it can't be
like Siri you can't be like oh you know
I didn't understand what she meant you
know okay it has to it has to 90% 99% of
the time understand what's going on and
if it really doesn't understand then
what I want to do is also build into the
system where you know conversations
going on and obviously it's having
problems and you know for a DV counselor
to step into the conversation so that
you know but you think of all the DV
counselors that we need on staff in a
call center or somewhere like working
like 24/7 like it would be a massive
massive amount of people so my my my
goal right now is to misty is to make
sure that it keeps on running without
the need for human being I've written a
little kind of like sneaky Python script
that is constantly like scraping the web
for resources and it's putting all the
information database so it's like you
know this is the DV resource this is
location work we can go here the hours
the name whatever this was the address
is a telephone number
this website this is we contact and it's
very very complex actually the way the
whole entire thing works because you
just can't put any body in every DV
Center okay there's some DV centers to
handle children some that don't from the
Hamel pets like then imagine like having
to make the choice of whether to you
know stay and possibly get killed or
like leave your dog you know it's a very
very hard thing if you don't have any
resources if you don't really know
what's gonna happen to your pet that
person might kill your pet you know
people you know people are evil so it's
one of those things where we're it's
it's more complex than just kind of like
asking someone to go to a web site okay
and a lot of people don't have the guts
to get on the phone because you know I
didn't have the guts to get on the phone
I didn't I guess it's the only one this
is actually the first time ever that
I've spoken publicly about it like this
[Applause]
thank you so so we want to so what what
I'm doing here is just creating another
avenue for people to be able to to speak
out I'm right at the time limit I think
we're somewhere near there and I want to
definitely leave time for a discussion
because I think that it's important for
me at least to kind of hear back and it
could be comments ideas questions like
go ahead open it up go ahead
well I get that list you said where do I
get that list right right so the
question was where does the list of
possible recommendations come from that
Jael can can undertake and that comes
from the hot line scripts so this every
person that goes through hot line
training has to train for every type of
scenario so that's where it comes from
initially and then also that list is
curated by a DV advocate or DV
psychologists so this is someone so you
know I've um I think that's a really
important part because there's a lot of
there's some people that are trying to
do AI for like therapy for like
teenagers and I was listening to one of
the NPR specials about it and it was it
kind of failed pretty hard because the
first thing that the DV psychologist
said to the AI was I hate my mom and the
AI was like I don't understand I was
like like that's the first thing that a
child sometimes is having problems would
say to you know an AI so that's that's
one of the things that's really
important to me is to make sure that as
many intense is like if I can think of
or added to the system that's where
machine learning comes in so that as it
gets kind of like this alpha use or beta
use that that you know it's being used
by survivors that when it gets into
production this can be as prepared as
possible
so it's not a production because we're I
don't have any of these things the first
thing is any of the lawyer but people
but I kid you not like the minute before
I had a prototype Christian Aman Danza
was trying to contact me for an
interview and his scrambled to get my
prototype done and when I finished the
prototype then people and they saw the
news story that people started trying to
use it and I had to shut it down
because it's not ready yet so yeah
there's people clamoring to use it and
then people started asking me for help
which is heartbreaking you know I'm
saying and I was responding in the best
way I knew how and then all of my other
so many friends that came out of the
woodwork saying you know that they had
been you know abused and and their
survival resigned I didn't even know you
know so yeah it's not a production yet
but we need to get it there fast
right yeah this is the hard part so the
hard part is that I think my fence is
that in the beginning it'll be really
really hard for jail to do any kind of
like therapy
okay it's really met in the beginning my
idea is to help people get out okay I
find resources once it detects like a
conversation that seems to be like okay
you know kind of how do I deal with a
situation and it's in the detail of like
therapy that it needs to like refer them
to get help because it's not gonna be
able to replace that counseling element
so yeah that's something that that
definitely will have to detect and it
was really trying to do is figure out
how a minute the dangerous because it it
generally is very imminent if they're
trying to find a way to escape it's
pretty bad
for sure
right right so that that's a very good
point and this is the reason why I chose
a setup through text messaging I know
that iCloud you know it's gonna kind of
screw with that but it's it's even more
it's the easiest thing that you can that
you can delete and and then not have to
worry about reinstalling it or putting
it on again and then and once you start
texting again and so this is a bit this
is another benefit of having an AI doing
doing the work is that if you call it
into a DV Center and you got someone on
the phone and you're talking with them
then you had to hang up okay because
your abuser came back and then you know
you had to call back in again who knows
if we're gonna get the same person who
knows the person that you're gonna get
is gonna remember you know all of what
happened if they're taking notes or not
or recording the call or who knows
so with jail they could pick the
conversation right back up after they
delete it like nothing ever happened
though iCloud challenge is going to be
hard but and people do destroy devices
it's a very common thing that happens
and domestic violence is that's the
first thing that gets destroyed is that
the device as I said it's not a silver
bullet but it's it's an avenue so well
off the work realms challenges
I think that would be hard I think that
I think it's possible for someone to
refer refer jail to someone else and I
think that you know it's interesting
questions that you know if you're not
ready for help and someone comes and you
know intervenes you know how are you
respond to that you know as people
respond differently so I don't think
creating any hard fast rule of like yes
or no would be appropriate like for me
at least it it takes a lot of thought
and unfortunately some risk-taking
weight bring them back
um sure right
if you want donate we do have we do have
a website that has donate Leon there you
know and I'm definitely not gonna you
know I don't want to like put a pressure
on you guys to like you know donate you
know whatever but if if you want to it's
JLA I and you'll find it the link to
donate there but we're training right
now that was happening we're training
right now with survivors and the hotline
scripts so it's not live in in the sense
that was open to the whole entire world
but it's available to us so that we can
and these are just survivors that people
I just know with friends and that kind
of thing so and me myself as a survivor
so is it's not of a very formal process
but if something that was going on for a
while and what I'll do is I'll I'll have
a list of I'll list out a conversation
and then I'll give it to someone and say
what does this look like it's like help
you forgot about this like what if that
biloba line these people who are trained
to understand DV like you know scenarios
would it be possible for the ruse words
to then have access to the conversation
right yeah
right so this is actually very important
and this is why we need a lawyer and the
partnerships because there's a lots of
privacy concerns there you know they
have to give they have to give
permission for that conversation to be
shared it's like anything else and but
if you know and really don't want to
start off a conversation with a
disclaimer like you're you're you were
giving jail the right to tell you know
to give this Reno that would that would
kind of kill the vibe right there I want
to be able to to do this in a way that
makes sense
and this is one of the reasons again
that I'm I'm you know for me
cybersecurity is a human right and the
brown program that I'm enrolling in is
it's all about not just about the
technology but also my policy so
straight for it
it will be open-source correct yeah yeah
yeah but I need organization in order to
kind of like do that with go ahead play
in the back
yeah so part of part of the impressive
[Music]
credential stuff that I didn't mention
is that a lot of the work that I've done
after Pandora has been for the US
military US military intelligence and
I've I've designed systems that you know
everyone everyone knows about the whole
like you know prism thing and all that
stuff and digesting all the information
and so basically what I I didn't do that
work but what I did is develop systems
for agencies to create analytical tools
and then share litical tools across
agencies and it's called the bdp Big
Data Platform
so you can look that up but it but but
yes I've worked with a lot of the
machine learning stuff for for stuff
that's oh seems to me like a it's a
zillion times harder to analyze than
this and then I also worked on something
called arc angel and that's a pretty
interesting tool because if you ever
watched like you know Jason Bourne or
the Bourne Identity or some like that
you see that screening that they have
with like you know the map of you know
some city and they're like zooming in
and like plugging in the cameras like
that's not for us pretty much real yeah
and and I helped build it and it
basically what it does is it is it
ingest all this information and then you
can actually do more than what you see
on TV it's like it's like literally like
a Google map for like threats and so
what it's doing is it's trying to figure
out like okay if you go from here to
here what's your chances of being
attacked and then you can scroll the
scrub bar back so and like go back in
time go forward in time and all the
stuff and he's ingesting huge amounts of
data from like you know like social
media and agencies and all the stuff
like that so
Oh
right so when when this aired well
before this aired I was trying to get
ahold of an organization in Sacramento
called weave and they're like kind of
like the top dog in the sense of like
you know helping women and it's being
you know their foreman and they got a
lot of funding from everywhere and they
were they wouldn't return any much calls
or emails and then myaxx Christina - you
know advocate for me with them and then
I finally got them in a room and they
listened to me and then you know kinda
like the tech phobia came up of like you
know it's a scary place this I tried to
explain to them and most empathetic into
Phatak way and I knew how but it just
didn't get you know they never followed
up so organizations like that is what we
need on board but I'll be happy with
anyone like an individual from that
organization or just a person that's
done it in the past but those
partnerships with those types of
organizations that get a lot of money
from the federal government from private
organizations those are gonna be the
ones that are gonna help us because they
have already fought the fight with like
police and all of the agencies around
protecting women's information in
protecting women's rights so they're
gonna be the best people to to be on our
team
making a weapon sorry a snapchat version
yeah yeah
yeah I mean I mean I think we can be
creative around that as I said I'm not
in closing a door I think as I said
about the whole cascading failure thing
remote more places that you can use as a
backup as long as we don't put people in
more danger and and and we don't know
you know we have to we have to test this
out but I think that I wouldn't rule it
completely out but I'll be very careful
with it I think we're pretty much out of
time and I want to thank you so much for
being a part of this and if you have any
questions from here on slack channel
thank you very much
[Applause]